Here's everything I eat in a day two weeks postpartum.
And as someone that loves to cook,
today we're keeping the meals very simple and quick.
Started off my day with a hot cup of fennel tea
and some water with electrolytes.
Still hate the taste of water,
so
I need to put something in there to make it taste a little bit better.
Started making a blueberry sauce and made some gluten free pancakes.
Once my blueberries had cooked down,
I blend them up
and then transfer it over to cool down
while I make my pancakes and slice my fruit.
When the pancakes are done,
I top them with my blueberry sauce and my fruit.
I also always take my postnatal vitamins with my breakfast,
and this was perfect since I was craving something sweet.
You guys know I always need to have my midday beverage.
Today it was an iced robus tea with a splash of milk.
The past few days, I've just been thinking about making kimchi stew,
so that's exactly what I made today.
I sliced up some onions,
green onions, some enoki mushrooms, and some soft tofu.
And I started by sauteing my onions with some garlic
and then adding in my chopped up kimchi,
my broth, and then all of my toppings.
And I also had some wagyu in the fridge,
so I popped that in there as well to cook.
Once that was done,
I served that alongside some white rice.
This Meal hits the spot every time,
and it's so comforting to me,
but I always burn myself
because I'm just too impatient to wait for it to cool down.
I had a little snack before dinner.
It was just some honey crisp apples with some oat butter.
At this point,
I was so tired,
so I just used whatever was in the fridge to make a quick meal.
I started by roasting some Japanese sweet potatoes
and adding some fresh herbs to
my garlic compound butter I made earlier,
added some Parmesan cheese to that
and top my salmon
before putting all of this in the oven for about 20 minutes
while I made some garlic chilli sauteed broccolini.
Once my potatoes and salmon were done in the oven,
I played at that with my broccoli,
and this was so good.
And I needed a little sweet treat
and had some homemade cookies and cream ice cream.